joining us now on this tuesday edition
of pftpm first round pick rookie out of
lsu national champion playing for the
defending nfl champion kansas city
chiefs he is running back clyde edwards
elaire welcome to the program cloud how
are you buddy
i'm doing good how about you i'm doing
great not as well as the kansas city
chiefs though off to a two-and-oh start
i did notice something though and it's
going to be relevant to why you're
joining us today you're with us on
behalf of tide which is participating in
the nfl's jersey exchange program
cleaning the jerseys first it's always
important though that the names be
spelled properly on the back of the
jerseys what the heck happened this
weekend
oh man uh i really don't know um you
know it was it was something i guess uh
you know it happened beforehand i didn't
even see it i didn't even see it before
i went out on the field and and didn't
realize it until after the game so
ultimately play the game
i mean it is what it is keep it moving
it'll be correct next week how many text
messages did you have saying hey i think
there may be something wrong on the back
of your jersey
surprisingly only one
i only had one ticket
uh it was actually from my agent
yeah so what do you do with that jersey
is that one that gets exchanged or is
that one that is a collector's item
um so as far as right now i have no idea
where their jersey is um
you know i actually signed it to to
austin eggler for the uh for the for the
jersey swap with ty
so ultimately right now um the jersey
should be on his way
to uh you know to to the charges to
austin so
right now i have no idea where it is if
it's if it is still at the facility uh
i'll make sure to grab it and put it up
put it up in the closet yeah otherwise
austin's gonna get the ultra rare clyde
edward zelaire collector item uh signed
to austin actor you're gonna have to put
a new number on there too assuming that
you signed it on one of the white
numbers tell us more about the program
that tide has going on to allow players
to exchange jerseys this year
so uh you know ultimately
a lot of nfl players like myself we're
excited when we found out that that we
could swap jerseys this year and that
was something i that i looked forward to
um you know all the way up into coming
into the coming to the nfl so
ultimately i'm thrilled that that tight
hygienic clean is here to to make sure
this game day tradition uh stays alive
and ultimately i couldn't be i couldn't
be more excited to to be a part of this
program
two games into your nfl career clive how
are you feeling physically
physically i feel amazing um you know
ready to ready to start this start this
work week out
looking looking ahead to week three
it should be a great monday night
showdown and
ultimately my body my body feels great
have you had your welcome to the nfl
moment
uh moment i would say
i would say
yeah uh the the moment
walking out walking out that tunnel the
first time
um and telling myself to take it all in
because this is the first time that you
would be
uh the first and the last time did it be
my first game in in chief's kingdom and
uh you know i just wanted to clear my
mind and walk out on that field and make
sure i took it all in
so ultimately that's the that was my
that was my welcome nfl moment that's
the good kind of welcome to the nfl
moment there's another kind though have
you had that one yet where someone's
standing over you or you're getting
chewed out in the film room or on the
practice field and you realize this
isn't lsu anymore
oh yeah oh yeah i found uh found that
out early this was probably week two of
fall camp
um i was running running a route and
then uh frank clark uh he he was he was
pulling back i guess i guess he he
dropped from his dn
the end position and and i had a flat
route turned it up the sideline didn't
realize it was franken and tried to
lower my shoulder into him so ultimately
it got my first welcome to nfl hit nfl
moment at that time so ultimately i
wouldn't uh i wouldn't i wouldn't rather
be anybody other than other than frank
honestly you know here's the thing you
guys have such a great defense that has
to make it easier for you to prepare to
face other defenses because you're
facing a great defense in practice all
the time oh yeah oh yeah no doubt i mean
we have we have some guys
we have some guys on that defense who uh
who who come and compete every day and
they make it like game day every day so
ultimately it it only slowed uh slow
game time down for me
and you know if that's all that's all
respect to our starting defense other
than patrick mahomes because i assume
that would be the answer or maybe it
isn't maybe i'm assuming incorrectly
who's the most impressive teammate
uh most impressive teammate i would say
is probably travis kelsey
he uh he's he's he's a he's a workaholic
he's everything everything about travis
is professional he uh pete
he's a he's a he's a
he's a professional and that's just what
it is so ultimately for a guy coming
coming in um young guy just seeing
seeing guys like trav who's been in the
league uh so long and the way that he
carries himself day in and day out is
something that uh that i respect about
him and something i respected about the
organization
what was the biggest difference you
noticed between the first game of the
season and your second game clyde
um
ultimately
the the biggest difference for for me
was was fans
and and you know that's that's just the
time of the time of age that we live in
now
uh you know we got there and it was just
a completely empty stadium and and
that's that's just something that that
um every guy on that field is not used
to um first game of the season
you know we uh we had fans at the at
the stadium so
it still felt like uh it still felt like
a real a real game so
uh that was that was the biggest change
um the biggest momentum swing so
ultimately just just finding finding
your own energy and and having
pretty much having that team bond of
understanding that
we're out here to do to do our job and
we have to be excited and willing to do
it
and clyde i've talked to different
players about this over the first couple
of weeks who is it within the chiefs
that helps press the buttons and get the
guys going in a situation like that
where you don't have the external energy
and it needs to come from within
no uh it it starts with pat pattis pat
is our pet is our spark plug he he gets
it all sparked off and and and guys feed
off of guys feed off of that and and
from that point on we we try to we we
try to stay all uplifted uh
i felt like a couple of times we we got
down and and pat is pat is always that
guy to spark us and ultimately he was
the guy that sparkles on the field um
also and that's what you want from from
your leader and and that's what he is
what's it like playing with patrick
mahomes
it's different uh he's a he's a he's a
special quarterback and
um
in in my in my time i've i've been able
to to line up next to uh i guess some
good ones uh with with joe but patrick
is patrick is special and and
he shows it every day uh he comes to
work and he shows it every day even if
you know it's the simple things it's the
simple things it may be picking up some
trash in the hallway but ultimately
uh pat is pat is that that dude he's
that guy that leads what do you mean
when you say picking up trash in the
hallway like he sees a rapper on the
ground he goes and scoops it up just
because that's who he is oh yeah oh yeah
no doubt that's that's who he is and you
know that's that's who he prides himself
on and
ultimately i feel like i'm the same way
so so being around guys who
who
want the same thing that just want
things around to be better it only it
only makes
work uh more fun and it makes our job
more fun how much have they been
flashing around those rings to try to
inspire the guys on the team that don't
have one to go get one of their own
it's it's kind of it's it's something
that's pretty much understood um you
know we see it a lot on social media but
just the vibe just the vibe of the the
entire organization um
the the hunger of everybody offense
defense special teams
we all have one common goal and and
ultimately is to run it back
he's a very good pastor that's a given
but on sunday he did some great things
with his legs uh is he almost as good of
a runner as he is a passer
ah that's uh
you know i'll have to look at look at
more of his game but ultimately pat is
pat is a a weapon with his feet um you
know i was i was cracking jokes with him
telling him how fast he is and and and
the things that i mean he
he can take off running that practice
and you're really not expecting it just
because
his arm challenge always he always finds
a way to do something with it with arm
and you're just not expecting to do
to to do the same things with his legs
so
he displayed that and that's that's with
i mean that's pat being packed he he has
that skill set and he's he's able to use
it at any time he's also got a pretty
good hard count
top of the fourth quarter first play i
saw he got you
he
they flagged the chargers but i saw you
moved a little bit right and the the
official didn't see it so it's not a
foul if they don't see it but uh he's
pretty good with the heart count
oh yeah oh yeah no doubt very uh very
distinct voice
and the way that he can he can fluctuate
his voice and then
with that stadium being so empty i mean
you just hear every little thing that
he's able to do uh when he's on his hard
count so
uh
you know that's that's something that's
something that he has that that that i'm
not you know uh
all the way adjusted to yet we would be
in an empty stadium you mentioned joe
burrow you're both rookies do you have
any type of a bet with him as to whether
one of you two is the nfl's offensive
rookie of the year
no no bets no bets yet uh only only
motivational texts
uh and only only checkups so far
that's that's pretty much it
what's been your impression of his play
so far because you know a lot of times
you've got a game when he's got a game
you've been able to watch both of his
he's been able to watch both of yours
oh yeah i'm uh i've been very impressed
and and the the thing is is you know joe
joe is is big on feedback and
you know i'm not a i'm not a quarterback
or a quarterback expert but you know as
far as the little things
i mean just just motivation that's the
only things that that that i can
text him or you know just just keep him
encouraged and ultimately i mean i think
he looks i think he looks great um
completing passes uh handling two
minutes
handling you know uh four quarter drives
the things that he's doing and the way
he shows composure is something that
that i've that he's always had but uh
you know ultimately we just we just
keep being friends and just keep having
cordial conversations you know there's
another rookie that we're paying
attention to justin herbert the chargers
quarterback i know it's not your side of
the ball to have to worry about the
other team's quarterback but give me a
feel for kind of the buzz
among the chiefs when the word was
starting to get around that it was going
to be number 10 instead of tyrod taylor
playing quarterback on sunday
to be honest uh i didn't i didn't even
know i didn't even know i was i was on
uh waiting on kickoff and
then you know they they were they
elected to receive the ball and before i
knew it you know i saw i saw justin
running out there and i was like man
this is
i mean i knew i knew he was i knew he
was there but i didn't even know he was
he was starting until until i saw him on
the field um and he played a great game
so ultimately uh you know just super
super happy for him him being able to
display his talent yeah what were you
hearing from the defensive players about
trying to shut him down because he did
look incredible and he's a giant
oh yeah oh yeah he is a giant um i'm not
even i'm not even on that on that end of
the field to even hear the discussion so
uh ultimately when they're on the field
i'm i'm making corrections and doing
some things or talking to the o-line or
pat on some adjustments that we need to
make on the field for our next go around
what are you working on clyde what's
your next level the next thing you want
to get better at as you get ready for
game three
um next thing next thing is is
ultimately just just finishing
finishing everything finishing fakes
finishing runs finishing
anything that i can possibly finish and
and just show uh show effort um and
that's that's what we that's what we
want to just display as a team
that's that's what we do downfield
pretty much just just fight for your
brother anything that i can do to to
help my team succeed um i'm gonna i'm
gonna try to do that and
give it up give it
my best shot
who from the ravens defense are you
gonna be on the lookout for
patrick queen
patrick quinn easily that's my uh
that's my my ex teammate but
you know he's he's on that he's on that
second level so that's something i mean
i'm going to see him a lot in the game
he plays linebacker i play running back
so ultimately he'll be in my he'll be in
my eyesight do you think you picked up
more about him at lsu or he picked up
more about you at lsu
i would say i would say i picked up more
about him
uh just because of
the time that that i was able to
get in and and play against him as far
as scout team or first team reps and and
going against each other just how
just how everything worked out uh i feel
like i learned more about him but but
ultimately we made each other better we
were always going against each other
one-on-ones
um anything anything that we can do to
get better i was always going against pq
so
we'll we'll see what all he learned and
we'll see what all i earn now is that
the jersey swap for this week or is it
does it depend on how the game goes
ultimately i think that's the jersey
swap for this week he uh he texts me he
actually takes me early this morning uh
and his and his first two words were
jersey swap question mark so
he already he already knew what it was
well here's hoping that they spell your
name right on the jersey for monday
night football can't wait to see chiefs
ravens clyde congratulations on the
great start of the career all the best
going forward we hope to talk to you
again real soon
yes sir thank you so much
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports